[Music]
in sad times news submitted by Peter
Smith a young micro influencer was found
dead after her murderer posted pictures
of her body on Instagram Oh
micro influencers does that mean they're
not that famous it means that they have
a small number of followers but like
bigger than like a few hundred like so
she had about six thousand six nine
influencer yeah I know that I could see
them yeah well I don't want to saying
that they mean cuz they died that's uh
yeah so this girl her name was Bianca
she was seventeen years old and she had
like I said about six thousand followers
on Instagram and she was known as an e
girl which apparently means like an
emotional kind of like modern times emo
chicks like oh I thought she was like a
game game or Twitter like a tumblr girl
a tumblr girl or like I guess like a
tick-tock girls yeah describing us and
so like she was really into like the emo
stuff watching anyway not thug life huh
yeah so this is what she looked like
so the story surrounding her death it
has a lot of like I'm I have come across
a lot of different information so don't
attack me I'm just gonna tell you what
I've read Oh get ready for that time I
know don't even matter you just you
can't even say that they're just gonna
do it maybe I can't say if you're
breathing okay now hopefully don't worry
guys I'll attack her for you yeah yeah
okay so listen this is what I've read I
think we're like a private investigation
like formalities we are we always are we
always are if I don't do my job right I
get worse a fingerprint tip okay listen
so this is what I've come across so what
happened here is that she was coming
home from a concert with this guy named
Brandon who's 21 years old there are
reports that they were dating their
reports that he was just a family friend
their reports that they met two months
ago on Instagram so many rumors Wow you
know what it's not your fault if it's
these [ __ ] idiots fault they got the
wrong information and they're telling
a journalist wrong [ __ ] so the cop said
that they were in a romantic
relationship okay the cops I believe
that her younger sister said that they
weren't dating that he was just a really
close family I believe this is I don't
know what the flexibility oh but then
the sister could have been lying cuz
then she's like oh he's overage so I'm
gonna lie to my family but then the cops
saw some [ __ ] and they're like actually
they were fun don't believe a sister
well another report thing that's like a
rumor that's happening is that he was an
insole and were Ritter
which is like when a guy puts a girl up
on a pedestal and like follows her and
likes her [ __ ] and all this stuff in
hopes of getting with her a spa and
that's another word that they're
throwing around in this story she was a
stalker I didn't even really know her
yeah but that's why the sister came in
it was like he was a really close family
friend so I don't know a big the like I
said there's a lot of [ __ ] going on here
in the story the point is here is that
when they were coming back from that
concert they had gone into this really
crazy argument which led to him pulling
out a knife and slicing her throat oh
yeah what kind of girls is a bad
influence what kind of concert was it I
don't know okay and you're not doing
your job I'm not I'm sorry and so we
need to hear what was going on is
because if it was a metal concert I
could see where it loves you yeah yeah
you could blame the metal or with the
trip-hop
what was it it's like if it was a jazz
concert it's hard to believe she's evil
so maybe it was scream core maybe oh I
read him and this reporting is that she
kissed someone that she went to the
concert with some other guy and that she
kissed this guy there and that Brandon
saw this and that's what led to the
argument I don't know how true that is
but that's what I've read and and so uh
hands up like stabbing her the throat
and like oh he stabbed her in the throat
split it I don't know I don't know the
details cuz I refused to see the photo
like I yeah that's why I stayed away
from this story I was like
so scared reach researching this story
and coming across the photos yeah yeah
yeah apparently he posted a photo of her
bloodied dead body like inside his SUV
and said something like she posted it on
this other app called discord yeah and
said like you find someone else to orbit
you [ __ ] just like that and um and
then so he was also posting on his
Instagram story this [ __ ] twisted he
posted on his Instagram story his own
Instagram story he posted he like
doubled down he wasn't just like oh oops
I murdered he was like oh yeah I
murdered look he's gonna go to check he
posted like sorry Bianca and like with
her dead body
oh jeans are so emotional and then he
also so here's some more photos that
she's had on her Instagram poor girl
yeah he posted a deer she has a beer
this is no Instagram saying here comes
hell it's Redemption right he also
posted this quote fall from Fight Club
that's that so odd [ __ ] video did he
write my role of fun of Fight Club is
you don't talk about
he's an attention-seeking little
something like your life and they're a
minute at a time or something that Vin
Diesel that's from know that once I live
my life away when he he's doing fast and
furious quotes after a murder what a
[ __ ] weirdo so there's that been in
New York and in New York yes in New York
and Utica you're from New York yeah
where's Utica upstate I I don't know
where the kid is actually damn it seems
like upstate sounds upstate because when
I think of upstate I forget that that's
New York right right New York state
speak so continuing on with the story
he posted these things on social media
which led the people that saw this call
the cops
good and they were and then he called
the cops himself and was alleging to
like he's gonna kill him like he killed
this girl
and he's gonna kill himself so then when
the cops arrived that's when he
immediately started stabbing his own
neck oh [ __ ]
I know dude this story's freaking crazy
he started stabbing his own neck and
then that's when he goes so then the cop
notices that there's like this green
tarp and brown hair sticking out of it
on the floor on the side of the road
this is a dead-end street too by the way
they matches her and then so then that's
when he was like who's like what
happened to the woman that is injured
and he was like she's right there how
did he say that everyone I don't know
yeah he was able to talk like his blood
flatten out or anything
I don't know but I do know that after he
was stabbing after he hurt himself he
laid on top of Bianca's body and started
taking selfies what yeah Wow yeah she is
so dramatic what a [ __ ] oh my god
kids he is so he's living in a [ __ ]
movie dude he's doing this show for
everybody I hate people like this so
there's a lot more time so it's already
long and then he [ __ ] got earthworms
and started beating them or like [ __ ]
no no no so like a lot more on this
story so in that moment well another
thing to point is that he did change his
Instagram bio to that day that it
happened to be his death date so he was
planning on dying and all this yeah
luckily the cops were able or I don't
know unluckily but the cops were able to
get him to the hospital and did life
performing surgery so he's he's
surviving this hell yeah he's a service
[ __ ] time [ __ ] psycho so uh how
the [ __ ] do you heal multiple stab
wounds to the neck yeah right maybe it
was with a Swiss Army knife and it's
very small
yeah yeah so the other yucky part of
this story that I feel gross reporting
but this is what is being said online is
that Bianca because she was like a girl
like she she's been online for a lot
like she was really really young and so
like they have like people have pulled
up things from her past username
and like how she would manipulate people
and like oh so they're saying she
deserved it
that's what people are saying why I know
what horrible well no one really
deserves to get murdered yes there's
people that are online literally typing
out like this is hilarious
they're [ __ ] twisted they're like oh
she got what she deserved these are real
people they think it's characters in a
show or some [ __ ] and so when like like
dies they're like yeah the bad guy died
I mean the reality is skewed cuz even
for the boy like I don't know what you
guys see but I see a guy that's
constantly performing he's performing
this [ __ ] act in jail yeah like he
has to be so [ __ ] he's so he's
seeking for attention one um conspiracy
theory here is that so her last posted
photo can I guess the conspiracy can I
guess it Joe you like to take my job let
me do my job
though uh-huh go because the guest
doesn't mean that it's real you could
tell me no okay
okay so this is the conspiracy okay she
planted it she manipulated him to kill
her so she could get the attention is
that is that the conspiracy yes so fun
okay so the conspiracy that they're
putting in the comments of this photo is
that this photo is a character from this
anime that in that anime someone ends up
shot like slight like slicing the throat
of some other character because of like
cheating or something like that
I don't know but the whole thing here is
that they're saying that she might have
manipulated this dude to do this which
is yuck but crazy yeah but what I would
go man I mean what good is attention if
Minnesota gained the attention I don't
know if oh what would she get out of it
were there any conspiracies about the
deer on her bed that's what I wanted to
know or the mushroom growing out of the
wall or the floating cat emoji
her younger sister and her mom oh wow
where I know who's who mom sister they
look like sisters yeah they're so young
so they're reporting that this dude that
killed her like met the mom and Families
no no the reporting that they view the
family is the sisters saying they're a
friend just because it's a family friend
doesn't mean they're not a stalker yeah
yeah most rapes and things happen from
women and murders - yeah they suspect
like the closest people to be your
murderer scary
so aside from that disgusting narrative
that she might have planned all this
stuff and she deserves it yeah if
anything he's a psycho and was like
maybe she wants this because of whatever
that story is but the other conversation
here is at going off of the potential
like he was a stalker and like they're a
lot of a lot of the conversation on
Twitter here is that you know like you
see this is why women are scared because
this is a type of [ __ ] that could happen
when you say no to a man like men don't
like they feel entitled something like
these type of men you feel entitled to
get some sort of something from the girl
that they like so much that is like the
stupidest way to form a conclusion it's
like you can't blink it the fact yeah
these things do happen right but that's
the same thing as me saying that's why
I'm afraid of black people come into my
store because black people always feel
because I see them on the news and then
they steal things I don't know I think a
lot of people have personal stories of
times they've felt scared to say no to a
guy like it's not just hearing it on the
news or some other place it's like
actually it happens where they start
raising their voice or getting like
aggravated at you for not doing
something oh yeah and it's like and it
could be the nicest guy the nice guy the
friend guy and they always the nice guy
yes you've never seen that side of them
before and you're like holy [ __ ] and
then you don't know do and so you just
like either let them have what they want
or you risk saying no and maybe like
having yourself hurt I'm all for self
defense and self-awareness
so it's not the fact that you want to
have your blinders on and be like oh
this is I want to treat everyone equally
but like my other example I'd be like oh
well you know I live in a poor
neighborhood and I have a store in a
poor neighborhood so maybe it's the fact
that most of my customers here that are
stealing are of this culture but not
everyone's like that right but you want
to look for thieves is what I'm saying
yeah not not that all guys are this way
you want to look for low self-esteem
guys that will take know in a very scary
way exactly so then do you want to look
for the bad persons trait versus all
guys are scared totally we're all black
people are this way or whatever you want
to look for that thief you want to look
for the patterns you want to look for
the thing that is like what is dangerous
and criminal about this being like what
do all these people have in common
yeah like women or men or whatever what
is the insecurity so you could read that
and you go okay this one's dangerous I
think it's kind of lazy thinking I mean
not not to blame anyone but like when
people are like but all guys who
disrespect women oh yes they should but
there's a lot of [ __ ] creeps and
criminals they know and no one should be
still there's a lot of [ __ ] up girls
too I think I think what for me when
this all came out was like a lot of guys
didn't know that women were scared like
they they feel like they're the ones
getting rejected all the time and women
or whatever but a lot of girls are like
why did girls say I have a boyfriend oh
they give you a fake number instead of
just straight-up saying no or whatever
and a lot of guys weren't aware that
when most women have been in a
threatening situation where they were
really scared of saying no then they
take it personal yeah so it's like in
both ways people have to understand each
other yeah instead of just making
blanket statements of like oh all women
are just [ __ ] up because of whatever
really well I'm not that kind of guy so
why would she give me that number well
she doesn't know if you're the guy it's
like you might be coming off as a creep
and you don't even know that you're
doing that [ __ ] yeah or maybe she just
had so many bad experiences if she's
just like I don't know about anybody
that's true you know or maybe don't want
corduroys to the club you know and
you'll get a number finally yep